[Musique]
le sénateur pierre laurent et le
secrétaire national du parti communiste
français est l'invité de l'épreuve de
vérité bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous
pour ce rendez vous donc de public sénat
avec l' agence france presse avec les
échos et radio classique et trois
grandes questions comme chaque semaine
pour vous évidemment pire le rend
d'abord est ce que vous êtes d'accord à
100% avec le le candidat que vous
soutenez jean luc mélenchon à qui vous a
quand même livré un programme clé en
main c'est ce que vous direz dans un
instant à lucile bréau
deuxième question le rassemblement de la
gauche est il encore possible selon vous
pour le premier tour de la
présidentielle à un certain en rêve vous
le dirai à lucile malandain enfin
troisième question est-ce que vous
souhaitez un troisième tour social en
cas de victoire de la droite et
notamment de françois fillon
la cgt on le sait agite déjà la menace
mais qu'est la messe nous rejoindra pour
la troisième partie de l'épreuve de
vérité qui s'ouvre sur une question
d'actualité
[Musique]
question d'actualité immédiate le chef
de l'état est bien sûr engagé dans sa
cérémonie d'adieu ça va encore durer
quelques mois
est-ce que vous pire le rang durant ce
quinquennat vous avez connu au moins un
moment de fierté les moments de fierté
auquel je pense sont liées à la réaction
du peuple français je je je je pense à
la réaction des français après
l'attentât de charlie hebdo à qui son
voile à ces millions de français qui
sont spontanément descendus dans la rue
et je me dis qu'à ce moment là on a on a
raté une occasion de s'appuyer sur cette
mobilisation pour faire autre chose que
la logique de guerre dans laquelle on
sait on sait on s'est engouffré il y
avait un je crois à ce moment là la
possibilité de s'appuyer sur la
mobilisation nationale pour faire plus
fort justement sur la cohésion nationale
à ce moment là par exemple sur le fait
qu'il fallait faire reculer la situation
d'apartheid de certains quartiers on se
rappelle de cette formule du premier
ministre et ça n'a pas suivi à l'hommage
aux interrogé sur un moment il y aurait
un prolongement
oui c'est qu'ils aient à ça pour moi
c'est la réaction que le encore une fois
les français ont su qu'à opposé à la
tentative de déchéance de la nationalité
moi je vous interdis l'abandon la
déchéance de nationalité du de ce projet
là ça a été pour moi un moment de fierté
mais avant même de s'interroger sur un
éventuel
motif de fierté de l'action de se mener
durant ce quinquennat il n'y en a pas
donc on pourrait retenir le moment de
l'adoption de la loi de la loi taubira
et le mariage le mariage c'est le
discours qu'avait qu'avait tenus à ce
moment là la ministre il ya eu dans ce
moment là la france a tenu bon il y
avait des mobilisations contre le
mariage pour tous s'adapte aux biens et
ridé aujourd'hui en majorité la france a
tenu bon et je pense que c'est si
j'avais une mesure d'accord à retenir ce
serait celui-là dame taubira qui dit
aujourd'hui que la gauche buts sur ses
propres renoncements
c'est elle résume votre pensée la mairie
sur ce diagnostic laon combien le chef
de l'état lui vivante quand même son
bilan un même si les résultats ont tardé
il le dit et il a il a tort sur toute la
ligne
je crois que son bilan si son bilan
était était si important qu'il le dit on
explique ma leçon prendre au renoncement
à à poursuivre sa candidature alors
qu'on sait qu'il en avait l'intention
donc je crois que il a été obligé de
prendre acte du désaveu massif de la
politique qu'il a menée et tout
simplement parce qu'elle n'a pas répondu
à l'attenté de ceux qui l'avaient élu et
elle a continué à laisser se dégrader la
situation économique et sociale parce
qu'il a en fait poursuivies au lieu de
l'est au lieu de nous prendre le
tournant il a poursuivi les politiques
qui avaient été engagées dont quatre
cannes après ses dents d'accord lui dit
que ça commence à marcher à il cite le
cic est notamment bien sûr les aides à
l'embauché dans les pme mais que pèse
mais on fait la misère car il ya eu la
semaine dernière un appel des
associations qui s'occupent de la
pauvreté il ya un million de gens qui
sont passés en dessous du seuil de
pauvreté
de plus dans les dix dernières années on
est à 9 millions de gens qui vivent en
dessous du seuil de pauvreté en france
donc je pense qu'on aura du mal à nous
expliquer que la situation sociale du
pays s'est améliorée première partie
maintenant de l'épreuve de vérité avec
lucile qui nous rejoint donc comme
annoncé lucile bréau est avec nous de
radio classique pour la première fois
dans cette émission pressoir lucile
votre questions à notre invité au 20
novembre jour vous avez décidé on l'a
dit de soupire jean luc mélenchon mieux
vous allez voter pour lui en 2017 vous
l'avais déjà dit à la première question
elle est assez simple est ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec 100 % de ce qu'il
propose aujourd'hui aux français jean
luc mélenchon tient là non pas si vous
me posez la question comme ça passe on
pour son je suis d'accord avec une très
grande majorité de ces propositions qui
sont d'ailleurs issus en grande partie
du travail que nous avions mené en
commun déjà en 2012
ya pas beaucoup de la séance mais il y a
mais il y a des différences et
d'ailleurs nous avons rangé rendu public
mois hier la contribution programmatique
des communistes qui s'appelle la france
en commun pour justement précisé
l'ensemble de nos propositions
il ya sur certains points des différends
sur certains points des précisions qui
sont plus importante dans notre
programme
ça n'est pas vous savez extraordinaire
que des des forces rassemblent dans une
dans une candidature présidentielle
alors quelle qu'elles ont sur certains
points des différends sur les leurs à
l'herbe à proprement parler il ya une
grande nouveauté chez jean luc mélenchon
c'est son penchant écologiste j'ai envie
de dire il prévoit une sortie du
nucléaire il est assez clair là dessus
il veut même 100% d'énergies
renouvelables en 2050 vous là dedans
qu'on envoie là dessus sur le parti-pris
écologique nous sommes d'accord je pense
que il fait ça on a commencé mois entre
la fin les numéros d'urgence
je pense que répondre au défi écologique
est une urgence et nous avons un débat
sur la manière de le faire je moi
personnellement je pense que
nous ne parviendrons pas dans les délais
ou il le prétend à remplacer à la fois
toutes les énergies carbonées et toute
l'énergie nucléaire uniquement par des
énergies renouvelables donc nous le mix
énergétique que nous proposons parce que
l'urgence à cause du réchauffement
climatique c'est de sortir des énergies
carbonées
ça reste un mystère des énergies
renouvelables il faut mettre le paquet
sur ça et on ne le fait pas aujourd'hui
en construisant d'ailleurs des filières
françaises dans les énergies
renouvelables et il faut garder à nos
yeux une part de nucléaire dans ce mixte
importante d'ailleurs rien donc en
sacrant les moyens à la sécurité de ce
parc nucléaire
et là-dessus effectivement nous avons
une différence mais c'est déjà un
désaccord message
ce désaccord existait en 2012 est ce
qu'elle est c'est déjà vrai bisou et à
la construction du programme de jean luc
mélenchon 2017 on a un peu l'impression
qu'il voulait imposer au final il vous a
donné le package et puis ré non mais
vous savez les choses ne se sont pas
passées mais c'est tout le monde le sait
de la manière dont je l'aurais souhaité
puisque la déclaration de candidature de
jean-luc ces fêtes sont dans certains
sans en consulter
donc évidemment nous avons nous avons
construit notre positionnement
présidentiel les uns et les autres
j'ai tenté ou à toute l'année de 2016
d'ailleurs d'infléchir cette
construction puisque je souhaitais que
nous construisions un rassemblement avec
jean luc mélenchon nous mêmes les
communistes mais aussi des frondeurs à
des écologistes pour se donner toutes
les chances d'être de qualifier une
politique de gauche au second tour de
l'élection présidentielle
bon maintenant nous choisissons le
candidat ado le programme est le plus
proche de notre nous aurions pu nous en
avions les moyens présenter une
candidature mais nous aurions aggraver
le problème de la dispersion donc nous
avons en responsabilité faire un autre
choix soutenir le candidat qui a le
programme le plus proche du nôtre
parmi ceux qui sont en compétition mais
nous allons continuer à travailler il à
partir le spectre du rassemblement par
mois vous mettrez le bulletin mélenchon
dans l'urne là sans trembler enfin
un peu de réticence enfin quand je fais
un choix politique assumé je la subis
bon alors jean-luc mélenchon il juge
aujourd'hui que les banques sont
injustes avec le front national le front
national qui cherche toujours son
financement on les écoute
c'est injuste parce que ou bien le front
national était interdite comme un parti
dangereux pour la démocratie ou bien
c'est un parti qui a des élus c'est le
cas comme les autres dans ce cas il n'y
a pas de raison pour un banquier de
faire de l'ostracisme d'ailleurs les
banquiers en général n'ont pas de mal
donc pourquoi tout d'un coup tout d'un
coup ça leur prend de faire des tris
politique âge plaide pas pour que vos
énormes d'argent mais je suis d'accord
pour leur donner ce coup de pied de
l'âne et dire aux banquiers ayez pitié
du front national vous avez pitié
observeront du front national vous non
je ne dirais pas la même chose parce que
moi je pense que une fois de plus cette
opération du front national est un
énorme bluff
je pense que le front national n'a aucun
problème de financement de sa campagne
il affiche un pro un budget d'au minimum
12 millions d'euros pour sa campagne
donc on peut pas dire que ce soit un
parti qui soit dans la difficulté
ça vous donne entière et je pense que le
front national est appuyé par une
partition c'est quand même assez mal aux
banques sur le principe sur la parole
politique qui ait dit ça vous pose pas
un problème à lui mais que nous soyons
non mais il faut effectivement défendre
le pluralisme et le droit de chacun à se
présenter à une élection présidentielle
on se lâche comprend ce que dit jean luc
mélenchon mais en l'occurrence avant de
répondre ça il faut peut-être vérifier
quand même 7
cette information qui n'est soi et soi
disant livrée par le front national
ils nous font le coup à chaque élection
présidentielle le père était un
spécialiste de ça comme s'ils étaient
des victimes du système
or ils ne sont pas des victimes du
système ils sont aujourd'hui tous les
jours
invité sur l'ensemble des chaînes
médiatiques ils sont promotionner ils
sont banalisés ils ne sont pas
contestées quand il avance des
propositions qui peuvent beaucoup le
débat attendu
donc je n'ai pas pitié du front national
alors que ça vous fait donc encore une
différence avec jean-luc l'argent mais
qui place le débat sur le terrain de la
mort s'il avait choisi de mettre
l'accent
17 injuste alors est-ce qu'on peut
accusé d'injustice un banquier qui
refuse de financer un parti qui est
quand même associée à une menace
fasciste par toute la gauche mais
écoutez il y a il faut combattre
politiquement le front national parce
que moi je pense que c'est un parti
dangereux pour la france
maintenant je pense que il y à il y à
des millions de gens qui votent pour ce
parti donc c'est un combat politique est
un combat politique on ne mène pas avec
des mesures administratives et
d'ailleurs j'ai toujours été favorable
et je suis favorable c'est une des
propositions importantes de notre
programme à la proportionnelle intégrale
pour toutes les élections
on nous a dit pendant des années oui
mais le front national va être
représentée mais il les représente et
donc et donc moi je crois que la
proportionnelle donnerait de la vérité
au débat politique et réconcilier les
français avec la réalité de la
représentation politique donc
mais ça ne m'empêcherait pas évidemment
de mener le combat contre ce parti un an
que je considère dangereux pour l'afro
autres thèmes
on va continuer sur l'aspect
programmatique il ya un débat qui m'ont
beaucoup à gauche en ce moment chez les
candidats de la primaire de la belle
alliance populaire comme on dit c'est
celui du revenu universel
benoît hamon le propose manuel valls
propose un revenu décent c'est un petit
peu différent une fusion tous les minima
sociaux
est ce que le principe même d'un revenu
universel selon vous comme le conçoit
benoît hamon aujourd'hui donc c'est en
grossissant euros par mois pour tout le
monde un coût de 300 milliards d'euros
est ce que ça vous paraît être une bonne
idée est faisable aujourd'hui dans
derrière cette idée il ya beaucoup de
confusion il ya d'ailleurs des gens qui
font des propositions très différentes
cette idée des libéraux des gens à
gauche etc
il ya énormément de confusion sur la
mesure et sur son financement sur l'idée
de ben j'ai personnellement rencontré
j'ai personnellement rencontré les
associations qui luttent contre la
pauvreté vendredi suite à l'appel
qu'elles ont lancée pour discuter avec
elles elles sont elles mêmes dans leur
majorité extrêmement réticente sur cette
mesure moi nous nous faisons nous deux
autres propositions
la première c'est qu'il faut une
augmentation importante des bas salaires
parce que parmi les gens qui vivent les
neuf millions de personnes qui vivent
sous le seuil de pauvreté il y a des
gens qui travaillent qui travaillent à
temps partiel des femmes qui travaillent
à temps partiel et qui malgré le fait
qu'elle ait un salaire se trouve à vivre
en dessous du seuil de pauvreté en
finale création de combien par exemple
ab nous nous proposons de fixer de
monter progressivement le smic de
revaloriser le smic jusqu'à le monte à
1700 euros on venait de prononcer son
fin de quinquennat alors deuxième
augmentation des bas salaires
parce que c'est un moyen de lutter
ensuite il faut une réforme des minima
sociaux pour les faire converger vers le
haut et pour les monter progressivement
vers le niveau du seuil langonnais
faisait à dire un peu près d'îlots il ya
une fusion quand même manière mais
encore parce que parce que où il y a un
sérieux problème c'est que ce qu'ils
proposent à eux propose de substituer
c'est à dire qu'ils additionne les
minima sociaux existants qu'il
supprimerait pour les fondre et là il ya
un problème de financement parce que
s'il s'agit de prendre le même argent
est le maître et c'est à sens donner des
moyens supplémentaires
on ne voit pas très bien l'intérêt de la
mesure sont faris qui est renouvelé en
partie par le bas une partie des revenus
de géants vous les montre en tous les
cas la société du travail
merci merci lucile bréau deuxième partie
de l'épreuve de vérité maintenant avec
lucile malandain de la fp qui nous
rejoint il est proche des victimes avec
l'eye fi bonsoir lui c'est votre
question à dire laurent où l'on soit
alors pensez vous dans la situation
actuelle à 80 ans à peine de la
présidentielle que le rassemblement à
gauche est encore possible pour le
premier tour il est nécessaire en tout
cas parce que dans le premier tour oui
pour le premier tour c'est à dire que la
question qui est posée à je croire aux
français est de savoir si un candidat
qui porte des idées de gauche
va est un vrai programme de gauche pas
celui que nous avons connu au
quinquennat écoulé va pouvoir se
qualifier pour le second tour de
l'élection présidentielle pour que ce
soit possible il faut que l'un de ses
candidats réunissent un très grand
nombre de suffrages plus que ce que
donne aujourd'hui à chacun de ces
candidats et avec les gens
de pouvoir on a trois groupes si j'ose
dire qu'ils réunissent à peu près autant
de pourcentage est à dire autour de 15%
vous changez situation handicape futur
de la primaire et bien sûr mais c'est
l'objet de la campagne c'est de faire
évoluer cette situation
je crois que macro on présente comme un
des candidats possibles qu'on présente
comme un candidat de gauche et qui est
un des inspirateurs du quinquennat a
lui-même d'ailleurs ne se définit pas de
gauche de gorge on perd deux grammes
son programme est un programme très
libérale qui serait en fait dans la
lignée de ce qu'on a fait pendant le
quinquennat d'ailleurs il a été un des
inspirateurs de cette politique je sais
bien qu'on leur pain depuis six mois au
candidat antisystème mais si un candidat
ait produit du système c'est lui qu'il
faut battre manuel valls manuel valls
dont vous me parlez de la situation à
gauche manuel va donc j'en parle
si vous voulez qu'on parle du programme
de françois fillon j'ai aucun problème
réparation des murs alors est ce que
vous faites le niveau d'entrée françois
fillon emmanuel macron mais il y a des
différences tout sinon c'est un bonnet
blanc est grand vers un sol un seul et
même candidat mais il y a quand même une
inspiration qui est à chaque fois la
même et qui est par exemple l'obsession
de l'écrasement du but de la dépense
publique l'obsession de l'écrasement du
coût du travail
l'obsession de la flexibilité et je
pense que c'est avec ses dogmes qu'il
faut rompre
parce que c'est ces dogmes qui nous
enfonce dans la crise actuelle donc je
crois que si il donc il faut qu'un
candidat de gauche accède et pour le
moment évidemment ça ne peut pas être à
mes yeux manuel valls donc pour le
moment nous menons la campagne de jean
luc mélenchon mais avec la roue l'eau
dans le monde en mars
la première organisée par le ps va se
tenir dans les prochaines semaines si
vous alliez voter à la primaire vous
voteriez qui non je n'irai pas à voter à
la traire parce que acquis en quatre
heures pour une raison c'est que moi
j'ai tenté en 2016 de d'organiser un
rapprochement de nature différente
ça n'a pas été possible et justement les
les uns ont été tentés de partir tout
seul et les autres d'organiser une
primaire entre je rappelle que la
primaire qui va avoir lieu à la fin du
mois de janvier a été calibré et la date
a même été fixée par françois hollande
lui même qui voulait une primaire sur
mesure le résultat il a déserté le
combat quelques semaines avant donc la
primaire aujourd'hui elle est totalement
incertain n'est pas que vous
réfléchissiez à une primaire plus large
on se souvient que benoît hamon arnaud
montebourg étaient des noms qui
circulaient que l'est la pl parallèle
gauche du ps faisait partie des gens
avec lesquels vous étiez prêts à
discuter
contrairement à l'art mais je compte y
aller je continue à discuter avec eux
parce que je pense que la meilleure
nouvelle que ça soit une majorité
collines et la construction d'une
majorité politique passera de toute
façon et moi je crois que si on veut
mener une politique c'est à dire si on
veut vouloir voter des lois demain
qu'ils soient des vraies lois de gauche
il faudra que s'additionnent les voix
devenue de différentes formations et de
différentes forces politiques dans la
gauche donc je pense que ce travail là
va se mener dans la durée
vous voyez bien mais ça n'est pas moi
qui ai choisi cette situation j'ai
essayé de tout faire pour l'empêcher que
ça va être difficile d'ici le premier
tour de l'élection présidentielle moi je
ne suis pas devin mais je ne vais pas
faire des pronostics sur la primaire
socialiste alors que tous les pronostics
qui ont été faits ces derniers tôt ce
soit le résultat il serait possible
donc je vais regarder le résultat avec
tree concrètement discuter vous vous
nous avez dit je discute avec qui eux
avaient le noir est que benoît avec
arnaud montebourg je discutais avec
gérard filoche idée plus il est plus
dans la cour des pendant la course je
discutais avec marie noëlle lienemann
qui déplut gens qui ont votre préférence
c'est à dire benoît hamon et arnaud
montebourg est-ce que vous envisagez que
jean luc mélenchon puisse se mettre
d'accord avec arnaud montebourg
je crois qu'on aurait aurait dû lui
faire ou on aurait dû le faire dès le
début de l'année 2016 1 c'était à ce
moment là qu'il fallait le faire
alors effectivement maintenant ça va
être ça va être plus compliqué hier que
c'est donc nous allons nous allons mener
ce combat tel qu'il se présente je serai
attentif à ce qui se passe moi j'ai dit
que j'étais je les dis lundi soir lors
de mes voeux je vais disponibles
d'ailleurs pour dialoguer avec les
femmes et les hommes qui s'intéressent à
cette primaire parce qu'il y en a qui
cherchent une issue à sa situation
actuelle
mais moi je suis sensible à la recherche
qui elles mêmes et à leur ville alors
seulement en interne la diriger
mais une chose est les autres actions
concrètes mais qui sait qu'il y à une
autre élection
ce sont les jce l'ensemble quand même
que ça commence un petit peu a grincé
l'organisation des législatives avec
avec la formation de la france a
soumises de jean-luc mélenchon
andré chassaigne tout à l'heure a poussé
un coup de gueule en disant que
lui-même coiffe candidat contre lui il
ya eu un candidat france insoumise et
que c'était aussi le cas dans d'autres
circonscriptions
vous n'avez toujours pas depuis que les
depuis six semaines maintenant que les
militants communistes ont accepté le
soutien à jean-luc mélenchon fait de
rencontres il n'y a pas eu de rencontre
des clips pour parler de ce sujet alors
alors qu'à écouter bon deux trois choses
très brièvement là dessus la première
c'est que andré chassaigne a raison de
pousser un coup de gueule face à des
députés communistes sortants qui
appellent à voter jean luc mélenchon ne
vois pas pourquoi il y aura un candidat
de la france insoumise ou alors il faut
accepter tous ensemble de se tirer une
balle dans le pied
donc évidemment là dessus je partage
totalement ce qu'il dit deuxièmement
nous nous nous préparons d'ores et déjà
ces élections législatives et nous ne
pensons pas qu'elles doivent être
subordonnés
bien sûr ça aura une influence seulement
aux résultats de l'élection
présidentielle il faut préparer donc il
faut des candidats nous nous sommes
ouverts à la discussion avec tout le
monde et nous allons rencontrer la
france insoumise et nous parlerons de ça
dans les dents les jours à venir
mais nous avançons mais ce que je veux
dire avant que vous parliez de ça parce
que vous abordez toujours le problème je
dis vous les médias en général par le
biais de des discussions entre les uns
et les autres mais ça n'est pas ça qui
est important ce que vous devriez faire
avec nous je parle des communistes c'est
déjà dire aux français que les élections
législatives sont aussi importantes que
les élections présidentielles et vous
devriez consacrer autant de temps
d'antenne à l'une élections qu'à l'autre
pourquoi ramener parce que c'est bien ou
non mais ça viendra beaucoup trop tard
parce que vous savez très bien que les
élections législatives ont lieu cinq
semaines après la présidentielle
on en parlera très peu y aura pas répond
pas mais oui mais c'est un grand
problème démocratique parce que le fait
de focaliser sur une seule élection
l'élection présidentielle qui est la
plus anti-démocratique puisqu'on va
donner beaucoup de pouvoir un seul homme
alors que toute la société demande qu'on
en donne beaucoup plus à beaucoup de
gens eh bien il faut changer ça et moi
je vous appelle à nous aider à faire
vivre ce grand enjeu démocratique et
l'élection législative et pas seulement
après l'élection allait votre message il
est passé un merci indique t il
troisième partie de l'épreuve de vérité
maintenant avec michael ms de public
sénat qui nous rejoint bonsoir mickaël
buffaz michel bos en parlerons bonsoir
est-ce que vous appellerez un troisième
tour social si jamais la droite devait
l'emporter en mai prochain
c'est le troisième tour social c'est une
formule de journalistes moi je n'ai
jamais opposé les mobilisations sociales
et les élections je pense que la france
avance quand on vote bien et qu'on se
mobilise en même temps les deux
d'ailleurs le meilleur exemple c'est que
le plus grand progrès social qui est
connue la france c'est le front
populaire c'est à dire c'est le moment
où la gauche a gagné dans les urnes et
où l'ensemble du monde du travail c'est
et des ouvriers se sont mobilisés au
lendemain des élections sont mobilisés
ou dans la rue en faisant grève en 36 au
lendemain des élections alors même que
c'était la gauche qui avait gagné pour
imposer que ça aille plus mais la russe
n'est pas là donc ça veut dire ça veut
pas ça veut dire à que la question comme
vous dites du troisième tour social
c'est-à-dire de de l'intervention des
travailleurs dans le débat politique
elle se pose que ce soit la droite ou
que ce soit la gauche parce que moi les
mobilisations sociales si la gauche
était élu il faudrait qu'il y en ait
aussi mes gosses qui sera élu par l'eau
peu importe le candidat de gauche qui
serait louis bien sûr il n'en n'est pas
dans intelligent de démocratie dans ce
cas là c'est ce qu'on reproche à la cgt
est la cgt dans le responsable
secrétaire-général finit par thiney a
déclaré récemment lors de ses voeux la
mobilisation serait d'actualité
si la droite remet au pouvoir mais on
sait la politique bien sûr
la police a vu de quelle annonce mais
regardez ce qui se passe avec françois
fillon
françois fillon annonce son programme
sur la sécurité sociale un programme
très brutale et il dit je gouvernerait
par ordonnances c'est à dire sans passer
par le parlement
ça vous chante mais bien sûr que ça me
choque et ça il y a une réaction du pays
semble-t-il y compris même parmi une
partie des gens de droite en france ou
qui se reconnaissent dans la droite qui
se disent sur la sécurité sociale il va
trop loin
donc ça veut dire qu' il ne suffit pas
qu'un homme dise je vais faire ça et
puis ensuite il aurait un espèce de
blanc-seing pendant cinq ans où il
pourrait faire tout ce qu'il veut sans
en rendre octobre compétents et vous
promettez des actions dans les rues
peu importe le candidat pour à partir de
mai prochain mais je dis oui je pense
que par exemple sur si on veut obtenir
de revenir sur des lois qui ont déjà été
votés si on les juge inefficace et bien
la mobilisation sociale peut être utile
regardez il y a plein d'exemples qu'on
peut citer il y a dans des entreprises
un jour un patron qui arrivent et qui
lit je ferme mon entreprise est bien les
gens se mobilisent et arrive parfois à
remettre en cause cette décision et
personne n'accepte et ne trouve anormal
que les salariés le droit de se
mobiliser pourquoi est ce que ce serait
différent dans les eaux danoises et
holly plein air à l'échelle d'un pays
dans la politique
l'intervention sociale est chouette mais
l'intervention mais là pardon ça a
échoué sur la loi travail vous avez
manifesté n'a pas échoué parce que là le
mouvement social avait gagné une
majorité de l'opinion et du soutien de
l'opinion donc l'idée parlera ceux qui
étaient dans la rue vendant messi au
parlement aussi et c'est pour ça que
pour passer en force à utiliser le 49-3
parce qu'il n'avait pas de majorité y
compris dans le propre des manuels valls
qu'il a utilisé ce ne sont pas les
fraudeurs qui l'ont obligé c'est une
plaie c'est l'idée que manuel valls aura
été que vous forcer à l'insu de son
plein gré euros retenez moi d'utiliser
le 49-3 ce serait risible si le sujet
n'était pas aussi sérieux parce que dans
une situation pareille
évidemment que le premier ministre avait
le choix quand un projet n'a pas de
majorité vous pouvez le retirer soit dit
entre nous c'est exactement ce qu'a fait
le président de la république sur la
déchéance de nationalité il a tenté
d'imposer ce projet quand il a vu qu'il
était rejetée massivement dans le pays
il l'a retiré donc alors bien sûr été
adoptée la loi travail et bien manuel
valls pourrait quand il au bout du débat
il s'est aperçu qu'il n'avait pas de
majorité retirer ce projet de loi et
réouvrir la caution il a refusé de le
faire il a utilisé une arme autoritaire
aujourd'hui michel édouard
le patron d'une enseigne leclerc ne veux
pas généraliser le travail du dimanche
il dit la loi actuelle va assez loin
vous applaudissez michel et dans le cas
non je n'applaudis pas michel edouard
leclerc mais ce qui est certain c'est
que je je pense que il y à une offensive
des grands patrons du commerce pour
essayer de forcer la porte et au delà
d'ailleurs ils sont la pointe avant
avancé d'une offensive patronales pour
généraliser le travail du dimanche vers
le canaliser est-ce que vous détendant
salariés des grands magasins parisiens
qui ont effectivement un tos maintenant
depuis depuis dimanche ils ont voté pour
cette opérette remaniement sur la quatre
vingt dix pour cent alors qu'ils ont
tort et vous savez si vous leur dites si
vous leur dites on augmente vos salaires
de 20%
vous allez changer sérieusement les
donnes du débat parce que il faut bien
voir que dans les grands magasins où il
y a d'ailleurs beaucoup de gens qui
travaillent aussi à temps partiel les
gens n'arrivent pas à vivre avec leur
salaire actuel
or je parlais tout à l'heure des profits
et du cac 40
mais les grands actionnaires lvmh par
exemple serait partie des champion du
cac 40 qui distribue des milliards
d'euros de dividendes depuis des années
alors qu'est ce qu'on attend pour
réorienter cet argent donc évidemment
vous dit à des gens haut vos salaires
n'augmenteront plus jamais et la seule
manière d'augmenter un petit peu votre
salaire c'est de venir travailler le
dimanche oui il ya des gens qui mangent
ils fait sacrer ya des gens pour dire
oui mais et on peut le comprendre
et moi je ne juge pas ces salariés je ne
les condamne pas vous êtes très en verve
très combative ou ne regrettaient pas
d'être de ne pas être candidat à
l'élection présidentielle vous le
souhaitiez
j'ai un jeu j'aurais aimé je vais mettre
mon énergie au service mais j'en ai
marre sert à manger en étant obligé on
n'est pas obligé d'être candidat à
toutes les élections a déjà été
conseiller régional je ne l'avais plus
je suis sénateur
en plus moi je ne suis pas pour le cumul
des mandats donc je suis pas pour
candidater à toutes les exactions de la
terre on peut on peut à la place où je
suis être utile différemment merci merci
la semaine prochaine c'est julien dray
qu'être proche conseiller du chef de
l'état qui sera l'invité de l'épreuve de
vérité d'un soir mickaël fabre faire
messieurs l'or
bonsoir merci
non